so I'd say like 80% of it feels natural
like all the cravings went away for
other Foods within the first 6 weeks of
the diet it was pretty rough for the
first 6 weeks like I missed just regular
like healthy things like salad and
apples like I I missed them and now it's
pretty normal I still occasionally am
like you know it'd be nice to be able to
have a salad but if I do that the
autoimmune flare up is severe enough and
and the cognitive impairment is severe
enough that it's just not worth it so I
I think that there's an underlying
problem that's causing these
inflammatory responses but we haven't
figured out what the underlying problem
is and so the diet keeps it in remission
and that is good enough for me at the
[Music]
moment